I like that the prime minister of
Iceland said when they figured out they
were bankrupt because they had turned
themselves not if from a country into a
hedge fund he basically stood up and
said now we all need to go fishing again
we need to stop banking and go fishing
the I think that one of the threads that
run runs through the last 30 years of
American financial history is the
increased financial obsession of
ordinary people be increased sense that
they should devote some meaningful part
of their existence to whipping and drive
in their savings on etrade to make money
instead of doing whatever they do
productively to make a living and and
symptoms of this or things like the show
Mad Money you know they're all cable
channels that are symptoms of this
symptoms of this is the way the markets
move around and I think that just as
it's just a view back away from it says
you know what what behavior leads to
happiness
this isn't behavior that leads to
happiness essentially it's it's it's a
it's a going to Vegas mentality taking
into your just-just-just
just spreading into ordinary life and so
my first piece of advice would be when
you think of your savings think of stop
don't think of trying to turn a little
money into a lot of money in the markets
think of just trying to prevent a lot of
money from becoming a little money just
think of preservation and secondly when
you think of making money
think of what you do for a living not
the financial markets they're all these
signals coming in to you to tell you
that's not how you should think of it
your broker the television set
everything the smart guy down the street
who got rich because he made the smart
trade but it's not a healthy way to
think about capital your and then and
then I guess I would say never feel
stupid asking a simple question
if the markets conspire to make them to
make you feel stupid asking the actual
wood is actually the smart question be
withering in your investigation of any
investment opportunity if you don't
understand what the person who's trying
to get your money is telling you look
him in the eye and say could you explain
that to me again in English and if you
don't understand and say maybe I'm just
stupid
but it doesn't make any sense still if
it doesn't make sense it probably
doesn't make sense and it the complexity
is not intelligence so I think those are
kind of big things people could take
into Velo their lives